[Musique]
oh
le propre d'un ministre c'est de
dépasser ce qu'il connaît et puis
d'aller visiter des projets notamment de
rénovation thermique d'écouté c'est ce
qu'on vient de faire les copropriétaires
ce qui a marché ce qui marche moins bien
[Musique]
on a beaucoup de logements sociaux à
trappes vous le savez 60 % de logements
sociaux parmi eux certains ont déjà été
rénovés dans le cadre de l'anru d'autres
le sont en ce moment même avec des
projets ambitieux on a vu ces décès
habitat sur les tours de castiglione del
lago mais malgré tout il nous reste des
patrimoines ce certains bailleurs
valophis en particulier qui mérite plus
qu'un coup de fresnes qui méritent
vraiment une rénovation permettant
d'améliorer la performance de le maire
de trappes a encore un peu de travail
devant lui pour améliorer les conditions
de logement des trappistes
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est bien
d'aller plus vite et plus loin notamment
dans la réhabilitation thermique des
copropriétés et comme on l'a vu au début
de cette matinée du logement social donc
c'est des chantiers partout qu'il faut
qu'on voit le plus vite possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je